In the future, we will all have the option
of having our stem cells banked ahead of time
so that any time you need new neurons,
new musclecells, new skin cells,
they'd be generated from this bank.
I realized that instead of doing this
tedious process of stem cell culture by hand,
we could use lasers to remove
the unwanted cells.
Take some blood cells, put it in a cassette.
Add chemicals to those blood cells
to turn them intostem cells like always.
The machine identifies the unwanted
cells and zaps them with a laser.
After repeated pruning, you end up with
a perfect culture of your stem cells,
ready to be bankedand used at any time.
With this technology,
we can finally realize the true
potential of stem cells:
on-demand functional cures
made from your cells.
Cures that your body won't reject.
Cures that truly work for everyone.